all right welcome back to Hannity with
still in beautiful Myrtle Beach South
Carolina
Center Tim Scott is with us we're going
to take some questions from the crowd uh
I believe your name is Beth long time
viewer first time caller
welcome to you have a question for
Senator Scott glad you uh came
to protect women and girls from
biological males competing against them
in sports and using their locker rooms
Beth
transgender ideology is ruining women's
sports and we have to put an end to that
it's it's simple I think that biological
men should compete against biological
men
period in the in the conversation
I've met too many hard-working female
athletes who've come to me and said it
is patently
unfair that you all allow for biological
males to compete against us we worked
our entire lives to be competitive and
that we lose a race to someone who has
not had the same physical makeup that we
do
thank you for your question ma'am what's
your name my name is Chelsea hey Chelsea
hi uh Senator Tim Scott how do you plan
to differentiate yourself from the other
candidates in order to bring Unity back
to our country thank you Chelsea I will
simply say that I believe America can do
for anyone what she has done for me if
we focus on restoring hope creating
opportunities and protecting the
greatest land on God's green earth that
is a good start I've also found
throughout South Carolina now in Iowa
and New Hampshire the three states where
I'm campaigning people are starving for
an optimistic positive message with a
backbone and conservative principles
underneath it
here's what I'll tell you Chelsea I
believe it is our responsibility to take
our message to places we are not invited
I speak at every place I've had a town
hall in a black church I'm going to have
one in a Brazilian church I'm doing one
and a white church I'll do one in any
church any place in the nation because I
want all of America to appreciate our
conservative values but we also
we also have to be willing to take our
messages and our our beliefs and our
convictions to the highest mountains
but also to the deepest valleys we've
got to do it in a gymnasium like this
filled with friends
or an inner city Church surrounded by
Skeptics you see I believe that I'm not
an exception
I am simply today's rule anybody can
succeed in the America we love take our
message to where they are
Well you certainly did that when you
went on The View I give you a lot of
credit I've been there it's not fun yes
ma'am what's your name yes my name's
Aaron and good evening Senator and Sean
my question is this in a world that we
know is kind of in a downfall and we can
all agree to that what are your main
differences with the other candidates
such as Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis
what are your main policy candidates or
differences yeah so the first thing
that's saying is that I do care who wins
the Ukrainian conflict I believe
ukrainians are willing to put their
lives on the line and I hope zelinski
pulls it out this summer offensive will
be really important in that engagement
but more importantly what I would say
the biggest difference is between me and
Joe Biden that's where I'm focusing my
attention he's our problem not other
Republicans and so what I focus on
as Sean pointed out earlier brother is
inflation 40-year High whether it's gas
prices 40 percent higher electricity 20
higher food 20 higher the radical left
and their ideology is a problem that is
like a cancer is metastasizing across
our country we are now living in a place
where the radical left tells you and me
that the drug of victimhood
is what we should take
the culture of grievance is pervasive
around this country I want to be the
president who stands up to the radical
left and says no more not on my watch
number one number two I'm going to
restore confidence and integrity in our
department of justice and number three
I'm going to stand Toe to Toe with China
and say stop spying on my kids
stop buying our farmland and stop
breaching our Sovereign borders
by the way this interview has been a lot
easier than the Gavin Newsom one um
ma'am I hi I am Jane fortune and I want
to thank you both for being in Myrtle
Beach we're tickled to have you
um my question is Senator Scott as the
the new president of our Great America
what will be your first executive order
and what will be your reasoning behind
that order
my first executive order would be to
restart the XL Keystone Pipeline
and
my rationale is that energy security is
National Security we can do it our own
we should do it on our own
[Applause]
the second thing I would do is honestly
secure our border
[Applause]
for
for less than for less than 15 billion
dollars 10 billion dollars we could
finish a a wall and for five billion
dollars we could use the surveillance
technology that is currently available
to detect fentanyl so we can save
American lives starting a s a t
great question thank you man
hi ma'am how are you what's your name hi
my name is Mariana
thank you for being here and hearing our
concerns we've been long time viewers as
a former public school educator for 30
years I am outraged and view the current
educational system is disgraceful I
would like to know who gave Randy
Weingarten the power to change things
my question involves the teaching of CRT
as well as transgender literature and
parental rights in this situation what
will you do to combat this atrocity and
reform it our children are our future
and everybody needs to remember that
absolutely
[Applause]
I believe that we must have school
choice in this nation in order
in order for us to take the power from
the teachers unions we've got to break
the back of the teachers unions which
means destroying the Monopoly they have
over our kids which requires us to have
school choice because every kid and
every zip code deserves quality
education we must get back
[Applause]
we must get back to ABC's and eliminate
CRT
just that simple
let's
let's just teach American history let's
just teach them math reading and science
since the since covid we've had the
greatest drop in test scores in American
history
Baltimore Chicago Los Angeles here's
what you can here's what you know about
the Scott Administration we would never
hire a Randy Weingart number one and
number two we want to hire Americans who
are proud of America
[Applause]
sorry we love you short what does your
hat say
well my name is Joe calabretta
says Vietnam veteran thank you
sir
thank you for joining what's your
question sir one of my questions is
about vets yes sir what are you going to
do about the treatment they get versus
the illegal aliens that are in this
country getting free food free cell
phones while our beds sleep on the
street
yes sir
today we spend around 400 billion
dollars on our veteran services we need
to spend more money honoring the promise
we made to our veterans when they came
home one of the things I've already done
sir in 2014 I had the largest Vietnam
veterans ceremony in our state we had
over 2500 people in attendance and when
I made a commitment there was to take a
look at our VA and to make sure that we
improved and reduced the wait times so
that more of our veterans got to service
you earned by putting your life on the
line number one number two we've also
adopted and I would make it permanent
allowing for veterans to decide where
they want to get their care
veterans today
many of our many of our younger veterans
would rather go to the local hospital
some of them are Vietnam veterans like
the VA system I think veterans should be
given the same choice to decide where
they want their care and I would make
sure that policy was embedded number
three sir
[Applause]
too many of our veterans
are committing suicide
they've lost hope
they don't have the resources one of the
things I've done is we've moved towards
telemedicine allowing our veterans to
receive the care they need by not having
to drive to a location but by using Zoom
or FaceTime or some kind of system where
you can get the mental health assistance
that our veterans need without having to
come to a hospital we need to make sure
that we open up every form of technology
to make sure that our veterans get all
the Care they need they've earned it and
we should deliver on it
that is a commitment
I will honor
all right we got to take a break yes sir
are we having fun yet having a good time
great to be here when we come back more
with Senator Tim Scott we're in Myrtle
Beach South Carolina thank you for
joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else